you bear this responsibility you've
created these platforms and now they are
being misused and you have to be the
ones to do something about it or we will
that was California Senator Dianne
Feinstein one of the lawmakers slamming
executives of social media companies at
this week's congressional hearings the
panel demanded to know how and why
Russian operatives were allowed to
infiltrate platforms including Facebook
Twitter and Google purchasing ads that
reached millions of Americans before
during and after last year's
presidential election here to talk about
it is Nick Thompson a CBS News
contributor and editor-in-chief of Wired
magazine Nick good morning Alex so did
the companies really know what was
happening here and can anything be done
no they didn't really know what was
happening they had some hints in fact
they don't even know now entirely what
happened no one knows the full extent of
how the platforms were used by Russian
intelligence operatives to mess up our
elections can the companies do stuff
better yes absolutely there about a
hundred levers they can pull to make
this harder and less likely to happen in
the future there were dummy ads on
Facebook fake Twitter handles what was
most effective from what we know I think
the most effective thing with fake
accounts so Russians set up fake
accounts as though they were GOP
political operatives or just Americans
interested in political debate and then
fake Facebook groups and those were very
effective at getting in the middle of
American political conversations and
riling us up or getting people to like
the groups and even trying to organize
little protests so that was much more
effective than the actual ads the
Facebook is saying that it deleted the
Russian accounts because they were fake
and not because a fount foreign power
was trying to manipulate our elections
what is the implication there that was
so interesting that was part of the line
of questioning that Marco Rubio brought
up during the hearings very smart
questions so the Russians created these
accounts and they used false names that
violates Facebook Terms of Service so
it's pretty easy for Facebook to have an
excuse to get rid of them
but there's no rule in Facebook's Terms
of Service that a Russian intelligent
operative can't mess with our election
and you can't really imagine a rule
where they say somebody from one country
can't comment on the politics another
because I don't know I like to comment
on Spain's politics or Frances politics
and how is Facebook supposed to know
who's a Russian operative and who's just
a Russian right so that cut puts the
kind of unfair burden on Facebook if you
expect them to do that so it's a really
hard problem to imagine Facebook saying
oh yeah no Russian intelligence
operatives on our platform commenting
about American politics well then how do
you regulate it right so what the
Congress is doing is they're regulating
the ads which is again as I said earlier
a small thing what Facebook has to do is
they have to change their core algorithm
and the core of the way the platform
works to make it less a platform that
helps with partisan dissent and anger
and outrage but that's a fundamental
engineering problem that hasn't really
been baked into Facebook's DNA so the
way to solve the problem is through
Facebook to get much more introspective
about what it does as a whole and then
its platform will be much harder to
weaponize that's quite a change how
sophisticated were these ads on Facebook
they're pretty good I mean I was kind of
I'm kind of surprised at how good
Russian intelligence operatives aren't
creating memes like they made funny
memes that look like they could have
been made by really smart 20-somethings
in America who were following our
elections I mean they're not the best
memes right there they're definitely
meme creators that like BuzzFeed advice
and Vox are way better than the Russian
operatives but Russian opera is exceeded
my expectations but they're not done in
either I'm right they're still
interfering on issues including the NFL
kneeling controversy they're trying to
stoke one you know dissent around race
and immigration this is an ongoing thing
right so all you might think that really
the problem to solve is American Russia
just need to maybe stop messing with
each other and that might be something
to kick one level up on Facebook right
is there any evidence Nick that Facebook
and Twitter now are actually anxious
that the government is sticking their
fingers in this oh man there's so much
evidence of that they are terrified in
fact you know there's a bill that
they've been opposing about sex
trafficking and they've been posing for
complicated reasons they just caved
probably because they're worried about
public outrage because they're worried
that Congress is upset and you watch
those hearings those hearings Congress
was just throwing the kitchen sink at
them all kinds of different anxieties
and frustrations meanwhile while the
hearings are going they all announced
their Court
earnings and they're making billions
upon billions upon billions so there is
going to be a lot of pressure coming at
these companies and on the other hand
though Congress is scared of these
companies because they have so much
power power and they don't know how to
they don't know Congress if Congress has
no idea yeah nobody has any idea what to
do here so be very fun to cover I look
we're talking about it in the future
it's very encouraged at the big time so
thanks so much happy to be here